Mr. Santos, you'll be.
Booted out of Congress.
Jorge Santos is rebooting
now joining Cameo.
The celebrity video message plat
Don't let the haters get to you.
Engaging in everything
from birthday to holiday.
Greetings and pep talks on Cameo
The platform's co-founder
says Santos raised his price
on Cameo on Monday from $75 to $
Due to the demand demand
from even inside the capital.
With Senator John Fetterman
buying a Santos cameo clip
to tweak, Senator Bob
Menendez, who,
like Santos, is also under
federal indictment.
You stand your ground, sir,
and don't get bogged down
by all the haters out there.
This comes as the Republican is
what seems like a revenge tool
against those
who voted to expel him from Cong
That is going to be the undoing
of a lot of members of this body
because this will haunt them in
the future.
Santos has already gone
after four House members on X,
threatening to file ethics compl
Usually you see revenge
as the sort of dish
that they do more privately,
and they find sort of a moment w
you know, to serve a cold.
But here he's serving it hot.
He's coming on Twitter
and he's definitely trying
to make make a bomb
and make an explosion with what
NBC's Saturday Night Live gave S
a sendoff
this past weekend
with a Wolf Blitzer impersonator
Disgraced and now expelled, Cong
Jorge Santos.
Is giving his final.
Press conference.
Okay. And not.
But Santos is hinting
he'll dictate his own career
in the public eye.
Now that he's cut off from his $
a year, house salary and benefit
Are definitely be ratified.
I have refused every single offe
for a documentary.
And he said he won't rule out so
other disgraced politicians have
A possible appearance
on ABC's Dancing with the Stars.
In the future.
If I find the spot to go on tele
in America myself
with my more left to me.
But Santos also has to contend
with a federal trial
next year on 23 charges
ranging from identity theft to w
to using donor money for Botox.
He's pleaded not guilty.
As for how that could affect
his media career.
The things that used to get
you pushed out
and make you disappear from poli
and maybe the public eye is now
maybe raising your elevation
a lot higher,
especially since he refused to s
back away from it
in sort of a Trump like approach
Another point of intrigue regard
Santos is the race for his now
vacant House seat.
A special election has to be hel
within about three months
if his seat flips to a Democrat,
which is a decent possibility,
then the Republican majority in
will be even slimmer.
Brian Todd, CNN, Washington.